Hello everyone!
In this short video, as you can see and hear,
I am speaking Hungarian.
It is my first video in Hungarian
so I truly hope that
especially native Hungarian speakers
will understand everything.
First of all,
I won't speak about
how I have learned Hungarian,
and I won't ask
if I am doing fine or not.
This is not the main goal of the video.
The main goal of this video is
that I'd like to show you
how important it is
to make the right decisions,
and how to stay motivated.
In particular, I'd like to talk about
WHY I have learned Hungarian
three years ago,
and why I kept and will keep learning it with time.
I have heard quite often that
Hungarian is not a useful language,
that it is spoken just in Hungary.
That even those foreigners who live in Hungary
don't learn Hungarian,
and that they only speak English,
be it in Budapest or in Hungary in general.
And as if it were not enough,
a lot of people think that
the Hungarian language is very...too difficult.
After spending some time in Hungary,
and after living wonderful experiences,
I fully realized that I really wanted to learn to speak Hungarian fluently.
And that's a key point, that is
we have to have strong reasons
for learning a language,
and that we don't have to pay any mind
to what others say.